foreign
Jeff is with us Jefferson Salt Lake City
hi Jeff how are you
thanks a lot Jeff
good to be here to be with you I just uh
wanted to before my collection just
wanted to quickly say thanks Dave so
much you know three years ago I was a
ninety thousand dollars in student debt
and as of today I am zero dollars in
student debt way to go hero well done
just wanted to say wouldn't have done it
without you man I tuned into you during
covid so my question is is there a
strategy to
uh to maxing out your Roth IRA should I
do it January 1st and get it done with
and put it all in Max it out for me and
my wife at the beginning of the year or
is there some strategy of taking more
time throughout the year to Max that out
okay well the the industry teaches
um a wonderful process called dollar
call staffaging
that if you when you're steadily
investing a little bit every month like
in your 401k or uh if you set your IRA
up to be on a monthly draw then uh in
January the market is down you're buying
cheap shares later on you're buying more
expensive shares as the market goes up
and it goes back down you're buying
cheap shares so you get this the average
of your dollars across dollar cost
averaging and you get to see this
wonderful mathematical thing happen that
shows your money growing and the other
benefit of that is is that it's not
emotional at all because you just plug
it in and never change it you always
invest now having said that what beats
dollar cost averaging
is a lump sum investment at the
beginning of the year
the downside of that is it's very
emotional because here's the rule here's
the thing to think about the market is
average 11.8 percent since it started
okay
so let's say it averages
it did an average year it made 11
percent
and you put in eight thousand dollars at
the beginning of the year in January so
you make eight percent on 11 now you
make eleven percent on eight thousand
dollars for 12 whole months right
right follow me if it runs average
and you Dole it out 1 12 a month through
the whole year you did not make eleven
percent on eight thousand dollars you
made eleven percent on about four
thousand dollars right right you follow
me so if the market is doing average or
up lump sum is the thing the average
comes from a place it's the average of
the up and the down so you can kind of
count on average now however you could
put in let's just say out loud you can
put it in and what would it do by the
end of the year it could be it could be
worth less
right right and so if it goes down
you know it makes it worse if you lump
sum it but if the market continues to
average what it is always averaged on
average you're always going to come out
better off lump suming
so I lump something but that's because
of averages and I'm you know and so on
average most the time that's going to
work
more times than not that's great yeah
but in and you know even if you made
let's see uh uh six percent seven
percent on eight thousand dollars rather
than
11 on four thousand dollars it'd be the
same you still make more money right
even if the market didn't do what it
usually does not is down but it's just
not up as much as it usually is so
that's why it works out so as long as
you can emotionally afford to open up
your uh computer screen and go oh crap
it went down and you don't freak out
right if you can do that and I can do
that because I never put it in I never
look at it again once I put it in there
I'm just thinking out 20 years I'm not
thinking out to two days Jeff if you max
out your problem exactly on that too if
you max out your Roth is that your full
15 percent
or what does that put you at
percentage-wise close close to it be
close to it yeah I think I have a little
bit more after that if I do it for me
and my wife okay okay because I was
thinking you might be able to get the
best of both worlds in some ways where
you're maxing out is this a Roth 401k or
an IRA
Ira okay but you can't lump show me 401K
oh that okay well there you go so he
could get the The Best of Both Worlds by
lump suming that and then still doing
some dollar cost averaging into his
normal into a 401k yeah that's true
certainly the balance over there because
you have a choice in the 401K you've got
a dollar cost average right
that's right yeah it does feel better
like I know you're saying it's emotional
I actually think it's even it's easier
on me it's January 1st I can just
do it all and say hey look I'm I'm like
almost my 15 for the year I can kind of
breathe and just get it done with it's
almost a little easier for me but if you
can set it and forget it and a lot of
people can but some people can't
so you know if you're not going to be on
Twitter going Dave Ramsey told me to do
this and here it is September and I lost
this money oh shut up you didn't
understand what the flip I was talking
about okay yeah I gotcha if you know if
you're not that guy then we're okay but
you know the whole most horrible advice
I've ever heard in my life the guy who
has told more people how to be
millionaires than anybody else I
listened to him for 20 seconds and no as
long as you're not that idiot and you're
not you're not Jeff no he's not an idiot
he's going to be a baby steps
millionaire here in a minute I think
you're right because hey he's paying
attention B's asking questions like that
absolutely